also tonight 2020 Democratic candidate
Hawaii congresswoman Tulsi Gabbard
continuing to fight back after enduring
a vicious slander smear and libel from
Hillary Clinton and her associates
actually suggesting that she by the way
is United States veteran she was being
groomed to be an agent of Russia an
allegation there is zero evidence none
whatsoever
zero basis in reality but listen to this
I think there's gonna be two parts and I
think it's gonna be the same as 2016
don't vote for the other guy
you don't like me don't vote for the
other guy because the other guys gonna
do X Y & Z or the other guy did such
terrible things I'm gonna show you in
these you know flashing videos that
appear and then disappear and they're on
the dark web and nobody can find them
but you're gonna see them and you're
gonna see that person doing these
horrible things they're also going to do
third-party again and I'm not making any
predictions but I think they've got
their eye on somebody who's currently in
the Democratic primary and are grooming
her to be the third-party candidate
she's a favorite of the Russians they
have a bunch of sites and BOTS and other
ways of supporting her so far Gabbard
responded in a recent video calling out
Clinton's repeated lies on foreign
policy failures let's take a look
Hillary Clinton your foreign policy has
been a disaster for our country and the
world it's resulted in the deaths and
injuries of so many of my brothers and
sisters in uniform devastated entire
countries millions of lives lost yet
despite this damage that you have done
to our country in the world you want to
continue your failed policies directly
or indirectly through the Democratic
nominee it's time for you to acknowledge
the damage that you've caused and it is
long past time for you to step down from
your throne so that the Democratic Party
can lead with a new foreign policy which
will actually be in the interest of and
benefit to the American people and the
world joining us now with reaction
congresswoman 2020 Democratic candidate
war veteran herself told Tulsi Gabbard
congressman first thank you for serving
your country and
thank you appreciate you being here a
lot of your fellow Democrats I don't
know they may be a little afraid of me I
don't know why I'm a nice guy but thank
you for coming in she's basically
accusing you of being a traitor you say
you you're being groomed to be this
agent of the Soviet Union with no
evidence you know I always complain
Republicans every two four years or
unfairly called racist sexist homophobic
xenophobic is a lot of a phobic and they
want dirty air water slander is a big
deal to me your reaction well first of
all I'm proud to wear the uniform of
this country I've served as a soldier
now for over 16 years still serve as a
major in the Army National Guard today
and have deployed twice to the Middle
East serving in combat and like every
other combat veteran have seen firsthand
the terribly high human cost of war my
job in Iraq in 2005 I worked in a field
medical unit where the very first thing
I did every single day was a
heart-wrenching task of going through
name by name every list of American
casualty and injury that occurred in the
previous 24 hours so so those of us who
have seen this terribly high human cost
of war we fight for peace we're not
pacifists we know that unfortunately
sometimes war is necessary to protect
our country but we see that war should
always be a last resort so what is so
concerning about what Hillary Clinton is
doing here is she is not only calling me
a traitor she is not only trying to
smear my character she's sending a
warning out to every veteran every
single American anyone who stands up
against the war mongering foreign
policies that really are her legacy that
have been so destructive and costly to
my brothers and sisters in uniform cost
the American people trillions of dollars
and cause such damage in the world this
is what's so dangerous it really Alisa
I'm tired of politicizing war we send
these kids go fight bleed die and then
it gets politicized never mind I want
the next generation of weaponry
defensive offensive we don't have to
send our national treasure our sons and
daughters to fight anymore especially
because there's no political will to win
it
rules of engagement under Obama were
insane in my view let me let me ask you
this we did have something called the
Russian dossier okay it was used the
bulk of information according to the
Grassley gram memo as as the bulk of
information to obtain FISA warrants on
Carter page quarter page I've
interviewed at many times he's
cooperated with our intelligence
services every time he went abroad that
dossier was full of lies even it's an
unverified dossier because its own
author says I have no idea of any of its
true that would be Christopher Steele so
if there's any Russian and in Fearon sui
had four investigations into Trump the
FBI House Intelligence Committee
bipartisan Senate committee Muller
report no evidence of Trump Russia
collusion what are your thoughts on
Hillary Clinton and the DNC paying for
that Russian dossier full of lies well
let me just say this interference in our
elections should be a concern of every
American because of the importance of
ensuring that our democracy remains
stable and that voters have faith in the
votes that we cast in our democracy and
I have said this over and over and over
again for those Democrats and
Republicans who may be concerned about
interference let's actually protect our
democracy by ensuring that we have paper
ballots or voter verified paper backups
to make sure that if anyone comes in and
tries to actually manipulate the votes
that we cast in these elections that
that can be audited that we have a paper
record of the votes that like that idea
otherwise and I've introduced
legislation to do the securing America's
Elections Act and for those who are
saying interference interference do
something about it passed my legislation
make sure that our votes the votes of
every single American are protected and
they will actually be count our
democracy will be protected let me ask
you this you're watching Adam Schiff for
three years he's told the American
people they have evidence of Trump
Russia collusion I mean the Mullen
report said that's not true now he's
behind closed doors and a secret
impeachment hearing now I'm gonna read
to you and I'll put it up on the screen
what Newt Gingrich afforded Bill Clinton
back in 1998 and that is the full House
vote authorizing the inquiry
he also involved the full house and
every critical step of the inquiry
defining scope establishing rules and
procedures we know that they granted
co-equal subpoena power to the chair and
ranking member at the committee level we
know they also allowed subpoenas to be
the subject of a full vote at the
committee level at the request or of the
chair or the ranking member they
provided the president's counsel the
right to attend all hearings and
depositions the president's counsel at
the right to present evidence
president's counsel had the right to
object to evidence put in admitted into
the case the president's counsel had the
right to cross-examine and recommend a
witness list now you got to tell me you
support this secret hearing of where
Republicans can't have access to not
even a transcript or do you think it
should be done the way Newt Gingrich did
it for Bill Clinton I think it needs to
be a transparent process you know I have
long expressed my concern about going
through impeachment proceedings in a
very very partisan way because it will
only further tear apart an already
divided country
my interest in concern is for the
well-being of our country and our
democracy as we move forward I think
there are areas of concern that were
raised around the conversations that
happen between Trump and the Ukrainian
president which is why I supported the
inquiry I think that inquiry needs to be
done in a very narrowly focused way and
it must be done transparently I don't
know what's going on in those closed
doors we as members of Congress don't
have access to the information that is
being shared and I think that the
American people deserve to know exactly
what the facts are what the evidence is
that's being presented as this inquiry
goes on last question why do you think
Ukraine and China would ever give hunter
Biden who had no experience with either
country a billion five in China ten days
after he flew there with his father had
no experience in private equity no
experience in China no experience in
Ukraine oil gas or energy you got
millions of dollars there why do you
think that hunter Biden made all of that
money what was what was the motivation
to Ukraine and China congresswoman those
are questions that
Hunter Biden can answer what do you
suspect it is though sounds to me like
they'd like to buy favor doesn't it
sound like that to you Carver's woman be
honest you could be honest really those
okay Joe Biden hunter Biden as a grown
man he can be held accountable for his
own concern is that concerns that
somebody with no experience is the son
of the second most powerful person in
the country got millions and had no
experience does that concern you I think
I think there are a lot of different
examples we're not asking about
different congresswoman not asking about
different does that concern you he got
all of that money with no experience
that is for hunter Biden to answer for
and to be held what do you think do you
think he should have had millions
I don't know hunter Biden very well and
I don't know who cares you know again I
think that does that meet your smelt
answer for that every year's militants
are foreign to be held accountable for
all right gets a little tough
occasionally on the show but we do
appreciate I want to close that you'll
get one last thought thought you loved
my show when you watch it all the time
okay I wanted I want to say that that
you and I I'm sure disagree on a lot of
things but I think that you and I agree
on on one very important point and that
is that the American people have had
enough of Hillary Clinton and her war
mongering policies and so I want to send
a message straight to your viewers here
today
join me support me help me vote for me
contribute to my campaign to finally
bring about an end to Hillary Clinton's
war mongering foreign policy and the
influence that she's had for so long
over the dinner party and Democratic
candidate will president invite you back
Tulsi gank you for being with us right
now with more on the